December 7th 1941.
September 11 2001.
and January 6 2021 well when he's in
here it's not our chair look I love you
guys your brothers but we can't be
disrespectful
everybody I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Ruby report it's March 9th 2020.3 we are
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals I am happy to report that all of
our live stream numbers this week have
basically blown everything out of the
water things are good here if you want
to join us for the post game show uh go
over to
reubenreport.locals.com there's a live
chat happening right now you can talk to
people that are in this room and other
viewers of the show and get me messages
and I may respond to them in the post
game show and you can correct me if I
get anything wrong by the way I did make
a mistake on the show the other day and
I'm not above correcting myself unlike
these clowns on mainstream media I said
that sununu was the former Governor but
sununu is the current governor so there
you go Dave Rubin made a mistake Dave
Rubin doesn't mind correcting himself
these things happen I will go to bed
without dessert tonight uh what we're
going to be focusing on today is the
machine Machine versus Tucker Carlson
because the machine is crashing down on
this guy right now I mean across every
uh facet of the machine whether we're
talking about the Democrats the
Republicans the DC swamp the media
social media everybody's going after the
guy as you know Tucker Carlson got 40
was it 40 000 hours right
sixty thousand hours sixty thousand
hours of security footage from January 6
he's been releasing it doing interviews
about it having his people dive into it
try to make some sense of it and
everybody's freaking out that we will
have trans
parency right they love other trans
things just not transparency I cannot
sit here and tell you that every single
video that Tucker is showing on his show
is perfectly edited and unmanipulated or
anything else he's putting his butt on
the line by doing it so I suspect that
he and his team are doing a hopefully a
fairly proper job of it but everybody is
crashing down on him and when you know
when you got Mitch McConnell and Chuck
Schumer in agreement that releasing
information to the people is bad then
something does kind of stink in stink
town
because that's where things stink in
stink town so we're going to talk about
that and then a bunch of other stuff but
I wanted to show you one little quick 10
second video of yesterday so we did do
our live interview at the local studio
in Miami with Russell Brand yesterday
we're going to be putting that up next
week we thought maybe we would put it up
this week or I almost live streamed it
yesterday but you know the guy is just
on a major major Blitz right now between
the the real time thing that obviously
blew up and then he was on Rogan and Ben
Shapiro and a couple other things so we
wanted to hold until next week and I did
sort of uh I wanted to do like a
postmortem of what happened on real time
and how his feelings about being in the
United States right now in the middle of
the culture War which as he said he kind
of accidentally got into like he didn't
mean for that whole thing to go viral he
doesn't really like the court
controversy at least that's what he says
but it was really nice to connect with
him here's just a little behind the
scenes is about 10 seconds after our
interview I'm with Russell Brand he's
exhausted he's talking to somebody else
say something to the people about
little Harry for my taste
he's a good dude he's just fun and and
just decent and light and you know we
got into some of the political stuff
it's kind of interesting because he
talks politics but he's really not he's
far more into sort of metaphysics than
politics so he comes at it at an
interesting angle anyway we'll post that
next week and before we get to
everything else let me talk to you guys
about Patriot Supply guys you know with
so much chaos and danger in the world
these days I highly recommend you stock
up on emergency food right now
especially if you live in a blue state
or blue City uh let's face it you're
gonna need this food and Now's the Time
to get it before it's too late go to
mypatriotsupply.com and pick up their
popular three-month emergency food kit
when you do you'll also get 200 worth of
survival gear as a free bonus you'll
need this gear When Things Fall Apart or
the grid goes down or anytime you might
have to fend for yourself you get
everything you need or to get everything
to you you need go to
mypatriotsupply.com your 200 bonus gift
comes free with each three-month
emergency food kit you order that way
everybody and your family will be
prepared but hurry this offer won't last
forever check this off your list and
sleep better knowing your family won't
suffer if the worst case scenario ever
happens zombie apocalypse etc etc
mypatriotsupply.com that's
mypatriotsify.com and you get free
shipping so come on what are you doing
get moving all right all right so look
what's happening right now let me just
broadly before we get into the specifics
just one more time address the the high
level stuff on the January 6th events
okay uh it was not an Insurrection by
any definition of the word Insurrection
that any of us had before January 6.
these people did not have plans to take
over the government they did not bring
weapons they were not shredding the
Constitution or taking over a branch of
government there might have been one or
two really bad actors somebody brought
you know some sort of ties and said they
might want to kidnap Mike Pence or
something but there was no Grand
Insurrection as if the government it was
going to fall as if the military was
going to be taken over in a coup like
there was none of that okay what there
were were a bunch of overzealous people
and some some I would say just good
decent Americans who went to protest
something that they felt was unjust
which was the results of the last
election Trump obviously for two months
was contesting the election uh he
repeatedly said in the days and and
really moments up to January 6th you've
got to go if you go you've got to go
peacefully he never called for violence
we had this complete sham
complete sham January 6th hearing that
nothing came of it right you can go back
to my videos from a year ago and they
started talking about whether they were
going to do this thing or not and I was
just like I'm not even going to cover it
because not only was the thing really
nothing right it was a bunch of
overzealous people in some broken
windows and yes you can't break private
property or public property uh you know
you can't trespass things of that nature
but I was like the thing itself was
nothing and and this hearing is so
obviously partisan that I don't want to
waste time on it and because we've been
through a couple sham impeachments too
it was just obvious to me nothing was
going to come of it so of course nothing
does come of it and then we kind of put
it to bed but then Tucker Carlson gets
these 40 60 000 hours of uh of
surveillance tape from the capital and
everybody starts freaking out now
McCarthy as I said the other day Kevin
McCarthy uh he could have given it to
everybody right he could have given it
across the board giving it to everybody
the the Lefty media would have ignored
it probably the the right media would
have run with it we'd still be in this
crazy situation right now this sort of
uh deficit of truth that we're in right
now because people see things people on
both sides see things they see the exact
same thing and they come away thinking
completely different things that that we
have to figure out that issue that's an
important issue in any event he gave it
to Tucker Tucker has now released a
bunch of this and is doing interviews
with some of the officers that are there
people that went and lawyers Etc et
cetera and everyone's freaking out about
it now
let me just say one other thing and then
we're diving into the clips I don't know
once again if Tucker is doing this
completely honestly I don't I just can't
I like Tucker I truly like Tucker I
think he is a good guy and I think he
actually is an honest guy as far as I
can tell right I don't know but the
point is why is it that by videos being
released
everyone is freaking out across the
aisle right he's not he's not uh
manipulating these videos because if he
was manipulating these videos people
would be countering it but they're not
they're just saying don't see it don't
look oh there's a fire over there look
the other way so that that's my backdrop
to all of this now I want to show you a
bit about how the system is reacting to
Tucker right again whether he's doing
this perfectly or not how the system is
reacting to him what does the system do
when you when you step out of what their
Overton window is they send the late
night comedians to go after you and uh
here is Stephen Colbert
thanks in large parts to the former
president there's a whole industry of
people who make a good living trying to
make you think you're insane
well I make a very good living reminding
you that you're not
now you'd think you would think
you think that once the people
gaslighting you on a daily basis have
been revealed to be Liars say in
multiple text messages in a 1.6 billion
dollar Court filing by Dominion voting
systems they would pump the brakes but
apparently some people are just addicted
to being dicks foreign
Fox News host and and toddler sucking on
a dog turd Tucker Carlson
here's what happened in order to become
a speaker Kevin McCarthy had to make a
lot of stupid promises to a lot of awful
people like Matt Gates
okay now first off if you laughed at any
of that please stop watching this show
if your mouth even moves slightly if you
literally were like
you gotta go you can't watch this show
anymore we're Banning audience members
there's nothing funny about that he has
20 writers to write that dribble okay
fine uh first if you want a little more
context to what it is that Tucker has
been releasing uh you could go back to
our Tuesday show we've got the link
right down below so you can see some of
the initial content that he has put out
there just so that you have context it's
interesting uh Colbert can call them all
these names and sucking a turd and blah
blah blah he's a dick but he doesn't
counter any of the information that
Tucker puts out there that's that's just
how it is so what is it that Tucker is
actually doing well one of the things
Tucker is doing is talking to a former
capital police officer his name is Tarik
Johnson and Tariq who happens to be
black I don't care but it does add color
to a world that is uh you know in a
racial Renaissance or something whatever
we're in right now at least according to
the walksters uh he talked to former
Capitol Police Officer Tara Johnson
about what happened that day and what
officer Johnson tried to do as the
events were unfolding take a look at
this once protesters moved inside the
building Johnson's first concern was the
safety of senators his job was to
protect them in Rising Panic he called
over the radio for direction and
assistance even now two years later he
is baffled by the response he got I was
requesting permission to evacuate the
Senate side
um the Senate chambers because I had a
clear line of sight to get them out the
Senate door and I didn't get permission
um the dispatcher called a couple times
to see if I can get permission no
response with Yogananda Pittman and his
other supervisors unresponsive Johnson
says he decided to begin the evacuation
of senators himself the person that I
thought was going to authorize the
evacuation didn't do it I wanted to get
those members of Congress out as quickly
as I could that's why I initiated
um you know those evacuations me being
disciplined it wasn't as important as
not getting the members of Congress and
their staff to safety footage we
reviewed seems to bolster Johnson's
okay so this is interesting you have a
capital police officer not getting a
response when he's saying hey uh Mob of
people and they're supposed to be evil
white supremacists and insurrectionists
and blah blah blah mob of people on
their way into the capitol could we
maybe get the Senators and the
congressman out of here he's getting no
response so he does it himself if if you
are all in on the idea that this was a
true Insurrection that these were
violent people who were going to kill
members of Congress overthrow the
government and Usher in a wave of Mega
Terror saying then this is the hero in
the story isn't this guy the hero in the
story because he actually did get
senators in congressmen out he also
happens to be a young black guy which
again if you're playing the identity
politics game everyone why don't why
doesn't everyone know him his name why
doesn't everyone know the name Tarik
Johnson here is a young police officer
who saved the Senators on January 6.
this everyone should know his name alas
we do not and you're not going to
believe this he got fired the video
shows Johnson conducting the evacuation
of senators from the chamber yet Tark
Johnson was not rewarded for what he did
he was punished a photo emerged of
Johnson wearing a Maga hat outside the
capitol that picture cost him his career
sometimes I look at it and like thank
you God for blessing me with this hat
and sometimes I'm like
wow I wish this hat never came in my
life a Biden voter Johnson says he
donned the Hat in an effort to rescue
fellow officers he believed were trapped
in the building I figured if I had the
Hat on it'll be easier for me to
navigate my way through the crowd it was
basically self-preservation and
de-escalation
um and I needed to get up those steps I
couldn't say what would have happened
walking through that crowd without it
but for the crime of wearing a trump hat
Johnson found himself suspended
ultimately he resigned from the force
and lost his pension he now works
part-time as a Furniture mover Yogananda
Pittman meanwhile thrived two days after
January 6 Nancy Pelosi elevated Pittman
to acting chief of the Capitol Police
late last year Pittman took a
high-paying job as the head of security
at UC Berkeley which is right outside
Pelosi's congressional district
Berkeley announced Pittman's hiring with
unqualified praise for her quote
steadfast commitment to social justice
Pittman herself boasted about her heroic
performance on January 6th her
Department she said quote saved
democracy that day all right so this is
really wild so Tarik Johnson he Biden
voter puts the Hat on because he did
have some concerns about the people and
he thought all right I'm going to get in
there as a police officer let me put the
Hat on they'll think I'm a friendly and
I can continue to do my work and if
people need to be rescued or moved or
whatever it might be I can go ahead and
do it this guy is the hero of the story
he ultimately got suspended for that
then as Tucker said he resigns now he's
moving furniture and nobody nobody knows
his name for the set of people that love
to really Drive someone's name into your
brain relentlessly often when they don't
deserve it as Heroes that guy should be
considered a hero okay that that's just
fine and then the follow-up on on this
woman who is now the head of security of
Berkeley by the way last time I went to
Berkeley uh massive protests our car got
broken into somebody stole my laptop at
my Nintendo switch I wasn't even really
playing it much but they told took my
with Metroid I had Metroid on that thing
anyway what's really interesting about
this is not just that a guy like Stephen
Colbert who should be doing late night
comedy but is unable to do comedy uh
that he's focusing on Tucker It's
watching now both set sides of the aisle
go after Tucker now again I don't know
if what Tucker is putting out there is a
hundred percent right I don't know if
they're offering a slant to it I haven't
seen all the things but what I'm more
interested in is the grand Narrative of
all of these things and now watch this
here is Chuck Schumer calling for Fox
News and Rupert Murdoch not to let
Tucker air the footage which is rather
wild considering uh there's
free speech in this country I think
still like the guy could air it and then
chuck could get out there and be like no
actually he edited it here and here he
lied about this that the other thing but
they don't want to do that that would
involve work that would involve uh say a
Quest For Truth they prefer censorship I
mean have you learned anything over the
last couple years here's Chuck
now
I have to address this because it's been
weighing on me
and it intensified after seeing Tucker
Carlson last night
last night Fox News
with speaker McCarthy as a willing
capable and Powerful accomplice
aired one of the most shameful hours we
have ever seen in the history
in the entire history of cable
television
Tucker Carlson ran a lengthy segment
last night arguing the January 6 Capital
attack was not not a violent
insurrection
and yet these lies continue tonight
Rupert Murdoch who has admitted they
were lies and said he regretted it has a
special obligation
to stop Tucker Carlson from going on
tonight now that he's seen how he is
perverted and slimed the truth
and from letting them go on again and
again and again
not because their views deserve such a
program
but because our democracy depends on it
man Chuck Schumer is not a good person
he's not a good person
um the idea that he is now pressuring
Rupert Murdoch a private citizen to
censor another private citizen this is
kind of like the Twitter files right you
send email to Twitter employees hey
could you look into these accounts we're
not really saying anything that's
basically what Chuck is saying to Rupert
right now Rupert
you're not going to let Tucker on air
tonight are you and also that he dare
utters the concept that he is the one
defending the truth again when you see
all those people with the hats going in
there and the flags and everything else
did they go in there and did they light
fire to the building like has been
happening in Portland and Seattle and
what happened during the summer of love
right did they Maul people and just
destroy public and private property like
we saw happening relentlessly uh for a
year in this country at the height of
kovid when everybody was supposed to be
locked in their house again they didn't
have any plans blah blah blah it's not
to defend criminal activity but people
who were frustrated with a certain
amount of nonsense and who may have been
bamboozled I'm not even saying they
weren't maybe Trump did bamboozle some
of these people
but were they criminal were they like
gangster level criminals who were about
to topple the United States government
like I just can't imagine the world that
you live in if you think the answer to
that is yes but it's not just Chuck it's
odd that it's coming from both sides of
the island that tells you that he's
probably on to something because here's
Mitch McConnell noted swamp Republican
Mitch McConnell and he's in complete
agreement with Chuck
it was a mistake in my view for
Fox News to depict this
in a way that's completely had variance
with what our chief law enforcement
official here at Capitol thanks
the thing is Fox News is allowed to air
whatever Fox News wants to air so the
chief officer of the capital might say
no this is exactly what happened blah
blah blah that doesn't mean it's true
that doesn't mean a news organization
has to abide by that again I don't know
how many times I have to do this during
the show I am not telling you that
everything he is airing is completely
unmanipulated or true I don't know but I
am for more information getting out
there like if you don't think that that
video of the officer of him being
interviewed saying he was trying to get
some help and couldn't get the help if
you don't think that that's interesting
or worth knowing related to all of this
then whatever then then yeah I mean come
on anywho uh it continues because now
we've got Chuck Schumer in agreement
with Mitch McConnell which doesn't have
happen too often and here is Karin
Jean-Pierre because she got asked about
it and her answer to this question well
this is this is Korean someone says I
should call her cringe Jean-Pierre
instead of Corinne Jean-Pierre here's
cringe Jean-Pierre explaining uh what
you saw in that footage
okay thanks Ray last night Tucker
Carlson Cherry Picked a video
surveillance from the January 6th
Insurrection severely downplaying the
event of that day he said the mob was
orderly and meek and that they were
tourists instead of insurrectionists
what's your response to Carlson and to
speaker Kevin McCarthy who granted him
access to that video
um anybody who watched that video would
strongly disagree anybody who watched
that video uh in a
with their own eyes in a real way and
saw what happened on that day would
would disagree with what was just stated
the president has been very clear
January 6 was the worst attack on our
democracy since the Civil War and we
should be focused on making sure that
never happens again
it's rather extraordinary because they
are literally like it's a meme it's a
joke but they are telling you not to see
what you see with your own eyes my
personal belief I don't think this is a
radical belief is that a bunch of
somewhat overzealous people got there
doors got opened for them barriers moved
you know what happens when a whole group
of people get together but then once
they were in the capital for the most
part the Capitol building for the most
part they were respectful and somebody
did sit at Nancy Pelosi's chair and all
of that stuff but this idea
that they were you must understand
insurrectionists like that this was a
threat to the United States government
is completely insane it was over within
hours and then even if you think about
it this way if it had been a real
Insurrection like this would have taken
months and months of planning there
would have been people all over the
country arrested for all sorts of things
because of the massive planning the
network of people that would have had to
have been involved in how they would
have maintained power over the military
and over the Congress and the branches
of government and all those things but
none of that happened so she wants you
to not see what you see with your own
eyes which which is a bunch of people
with Red Hats walking in and kind of
just looking around that's basically
what happened that basically is what
happened but she does not want you to
see that I think that's what our next
video is you shouldn't even be allowed
to see it
though basically all of the footage
should be released so people can see it
within its full context so the president
believes we need to get to the bottom of
what happened on a very dark day in our
democracy the president has been very
clear about that we need to get to the
bottom of what occurred the footage that
we have seen the footage that the
American people have seen uh is
devastating uh and what we saw was an
attack on our constitution was an attack
on our democracy
okay again we didn't see an attack on
our constitution or on our democracy I
also want to back up for a second
because she said in the previous video
that President Biden has called this the
worst attack on our democracy since the
Civil War
um
I was in New York for 9 11. I lived in
New York I lived on 90th and 1st about a
block away from the the mayor's
residence over there uh I was there for
years after that but for those weeks
after the absolute weeks and months and
and really years uh the absolute
devastation my dad could not get home to
my mom I had to stay in the city my
grandma who lived in the city my dad
ended up going to her place he couldn't
get all the way up to my place walked
across town with a bunch of his
employees who slept at my Grandma's
place it was an absolute abject
nightmare thousands of deaths over 2 000
deaths that was an actual attack on our
democracy this certainly was not that
but these people they lie about
everything they they inflate certain
things that they want you to be really
scared about and they deflate or just
outright hide or censor things that they
don't want you to know about and here's
Karin jump here with an abject 100 lie
go the mall yesterday you guys report it
on it who have condemned this false
depiction of the unprecedented violent
attack on cons on our Constitution and
the rule of law which caused police
police officers their lives and that's
what we saw in that day on a very dark
day an attack on our democracy caused
police officers their lives actually one
police officer did die Days Later of a
heart attack right it was a heart attack
Brian sydnick okay but it did not cost
police officers their lives they did not
take anyone hostage they did not
waterboard anybody or anything like that
so this is just what they do with
everything but now what I want to link
this to is how the lies get laundered
through the machine so you have late
night hosts just abject lying and just
mocking the guy for putting out what
most people would just say should be
just be public information if this was
the Insurrection of all time how about
we just see the video and everyone can
decide what level of inside vanity this
was and what should be done about it
right like if you guys want to make your
case why are you the ones that need to
hide the information to make your case
right so you got a guy like Colbert who
does his version of the lie you have
Corinne Jean-Pierre who does her version
of the lie you have Chuck and you have
McConnell who are agreeing nobody should
see any of this and we should probably
pressure the people to make sure that
the guy who's releasing this doesn't
even get on television tonight I mean
that's absolutely extraordinary that
Chuck said that so it's the government
and the media working together and they
somehow are always working together
against you which is starting to become
a problem if you ask me uh here is what
we Goldberg oh Lord
there you go oh we changed it we changed
it for you we used to call this a pure
and I thought that was just
like it is true that is factually sound
but I just thought it was a little bit
much can we put that up again I think
this is a better way to describe the
ladies of the view this next clip shows
shows a certifiably crazy person uh here
is Whoopi Goldberg saying that the
government should shut down Fox and that
somehow the First Amendment doesn't
protect speech actually watch this I
have a question how come this is not
thought of as
being recruiting how come they're not
thinking about the questions
why isn't why why is this not being
scrutinized the way that they scrutinize
other yeah well because to me this is
this should be against the law you
should not be able to lay to lie to the
American knowingly and you know it's one
thing if you made a mistake and you
didn't know but we heard for five or six
years how you know the media was a lion
sack of dude they were fake news they
were this so how come what is that what
is our what do we do as Americans to to
say this is not okay into the first
amendment I think you well no the First
Amendment doesn't allow you to willingly
learn
whoopee you human whoopee cushion yes
the First Amendment does allow you to
willingly lie you have lied and the
ladies that you sit next to have lied
about virtually everything for the past
five years very fine people on both
sides the covid vaccine Works no mandate
is coming Jesse Smollett was going to be
hanged we could continue you guys lie
about everything just in the last couple
weeks how many times have we played
things where you lie you lied about
don't say gay by the way we checked
yesterday on the show turns out no gay
people have been arrested in Florida yet
by saying gay or even a straight person
who might say gay you guys lied about
the AP uh African-American studies thing
you are allowed to lie because of the
first amendment I would prefer that
people like you on shows like that that
for some reason brainwashed NPC's watch
I would prefer that you didn't lie but
you are allowed to lie and I and I don't
want to put you in jail for lying okay
but again what she's upset about here is
that Tucker is real releasing more
information not hiding information you
may not like the results of it
okay you may not like the way he's doing
it but he's giving us more information
right not hiding information that is a
fundamental difference but the fact once
again that that woman gets up there on
that live television show that is the
number one rated show in daytime
television which is on at the exact same
time we do this so God bless you for
watching this instead of watching that
pure tripe okay uh but that she gets up
there and then literally she's telling
you you shouldn't be allowed to lie
while she's lying about the First
Amendment
huh
here's Adam kinzinger he's also a noted
liar and he's calling Tucker a liar so
liar liar pants on fire here we go
but he doesn't care because he wants
people's money he has an unserious man
who is doing serious damage with the
cooperation of Kevin McCarthy who wants
to have Tucker Carlson on a speed dial
because he likes to impress people in
the room with who's on his speed dial
this is dangerous and uh you know
Michael finone will tell you about how
all dangerous that was because it was it
was a really bad day that is being
whitewashed but the kids of the people
that believe that somehow that wasn't an
Insurrection they're gonna they're gonna
know better and the parents will never
admit they ever believed it in the first
place it's just words they just put
words together to scare people and
Tapper sits there with this fake newsman
glasses and pretends that it's all real
again where are the plans was anyone
taken over the nuclear codes were
military members running into the Senate
under the auspices of trumpton and mega
wishes and gonna take it's all silly
drivel uh here is uh Jake Tapper and
Jake Jake the thing with Jake is he was
the one semi-sane guy there but I get it
if you're if you're in a mental let's
say you're a semi-sane guy and they
throw you unjustly into a mental
institution which is what MSNBC and CNN
in this case are eventually you're going
to go crazy too because it's it's hard
to be the one same guy at the mental
institution you know I actually had a
cousin who wants something happened she
got unjustly thrown in into a mental
institution for a weekend and she came
out crazier than she went in it's a
freaking long-ass story I'll tell you
guys some other time but that's what in
essence happened to Jake Tapper here he
is gaslighting his own audience into
pretending that fox believes that
January 6 didn't happen at all you know
I know it probably is pretty upsetting
personally to have been there and in
your case uh officer Fanon to have been
physically harmed severely and see this
entire presentation pretending that this
didn't happen uh and I want you to know
we see you we know it happened and
I don't know what to say about this
except I'm sorry
we see you like he's an avatar remember
the Avatar we see I see you I see you
something
look nobody on Fox I've watched enough
of the clips nobody's saying it didn't
happen the question is what actually
happened how did it happen and to what
degree was it actual criminal behavior
and intentional versus just saying it
was an Insurrection and it was the worst
thing ever and people should be thrown
in jail and have trials delayed and they
should be an isolated uh you know
containment and all of that stuff anyway
it just continues on CNN here is
Anderson Cooper you know it's funny we
don't show a lot of Anderson Cooper what
happened to him he was like everyone
thought he was going to be like some big
shot one day you know he's uh he came
from a lot of money got on television
people seem to like his salt and pepper
hair but he kind of became nothing
anyway here he is uh interviewing that
same Capitol police officer and they're
going off on Tucker the idea of turkey
Carlson
being in that mob that day and not
wetting his pants is hard to imagine I
mean I I find it hard to understand
somebody who has never put himself In
Harm's Way in in any capacity for anyone
else or on reporting a story and yet has
the audacity to
try to rewrite history Tucker Carlson is
you know by his own admission and
Entertainer not a journalist
um and on top of that he's just proven
himself to be uh Donald Trump's Chief
propagandist and that's all this was and
I think that uh you know most Americans
recognize that
uh way before this segment aired that
this was propaganda and it was an
attempt by Tucker Carlson to uh to
downplay and whitewash the events of
January 6th notice they never talk about
the specific events of January 6th right
it's only their whitewashing the events
but what are the events I mean is it
don't you find it interesting that we
now know that a capital police officer
was calling for backup to get Senators
out of the building and he was being
ignored and then had to do it on his own
and that guy doesn't even work at the
Capitol anymore does that seem
interesting to you like that actually is
interesting to me that's a new piece of
information about this and and just
Anderson the way he talks about it as if
Anderson's always putting himself in In
Harm's Way right I mean he was born with
a silver spoon his mouth he's Gloria
Vandal Bill's daughter Google it like
the guy he's doing okay don't worry
about Anderson Cooper uh but let's
continue because the machine itself what
we know about the machine is that the
machine will always protect the machine
and that seems to be what's happening
here again I'm not I'm actually not even
that interested in the January 6th story
it's why I've barely covered it I didn't
think it was much of anything I knew
what they were going to do with it and
that's why I've tried to ignore it and
hopefully I won't have to spend much
time after this and by the way you know
one of the bigger issues this is sort of
like the Twitter file situation which is
the Twitter Files come out we literally
like it's without question please fact
check me newsguard without question find
out that the government was working with
Twitter to silence private citizens 100
we know it and we also know that the
government paid Twitter to do some of
that work that has been exposed for sure
the question is did that wake anybody up
now I know you're watching this right
now and you got it you were like wow
that does confirm an awful lot of the
stuff that I've been thinking and I
should probably tell my wife or husband
about that but all of the people on the
other side it doesn't move anybody and I
think that that's sort of what's going
to happen here with this thing those of
us who sort of felt felt that January 6
was kind of nonsense and that the
government was cracking down on people
for their own nefarious reasons
everything else will be sort of boldened
into that right like we will be hardened
into that idea and the people who just
think Tucker is evil and fox is evil
they're they're going to go the other
way so I don't think that if you look at
sort of like every reaction has a every
action has a reaction I think we just
kind of just stay still after this whole
thing but the machine is extremely good
at protecting itself which is why Chuck
Schumer and Mitch McConnell are suddenly
on the same side right like that is
freaking Bizarro unless you understand
that they're praying to the altar of the
machine uh now here speaking of the
machine fauci he's back baby you know he
retired got his 400 plus k a year
pension highest paid person in the
federal government he should be shamed
this man should not be allowed to go to
a restaurant without uh being yelled at
right like I'm not for that sort of
thing this that's more of a Democrat
that's more of a Maxine Waters situation
but bouchi should be ashamed wherever he
goes that he knows he had a tremendous
amount to do with all of the kids with
learning disabilities now who were
kicked out of schools all of the people
who injected themselves with God knows
what and now have all sorts of vaccine
injuries by beep Justin Bieber's eye
isn't working like a whole bunch of
weird stuff anyway Percy's still on
television he went on Anderson Cooper I
can't believe it we're playing two
Anderson Cooper Clips it back to back uh
and he's never been prouder of what he's
done the guy is just the best and he
still wants everyone to know it
obviously become very partisan as you
mentioned House Republicans are holding
a coveted hearing tamari tomorrow you're
obviously someone they are have been
focused on would you testify if they
asked you
of course oh without a doubt if they ask
me I definitely will testify senator
Paul just today on Fox News accused you
of orchestrating a cover-up do you have
any reason to think the new Congress is
going to be any less contentious or do
you think they're actually interested in
seeking the truth
well I don't know uh Anderson I I don't
really want to comment on that I mean
the most important thing we've got to do
is stick with data stick with science be
transparent and be honest which I have
been very much so literally for the
entire 50 years that I've been at the
NIH
yeah liar liar pants on fire stick with
data stick with science really because
this was a virus even at the peak of the
thing that over 99 of people survived
okay that was one thing you were lying
publicly saying that masks work while
you were emailing friends who wanted to
go on vacation saying masks don't work
you claim that you never wanted schools
to close but we have plenty of videos of
you saying that they uh that they should
close you lied about the vaccines and
the efficacy of the vaccines like but
the gall of these people but you have to
understand they're emboldened to keep
going because the machine protects the
machine it's it's wild it's it's a mafia
racket but not everyone is falling for
it there are little pockets of places
little say states where Freedom matters
can you see where I'm going with this
already and things are being done
properly in a certain amount of places
and yes it starts in Florida so the
other crazy thing that is happening
right now is that tennis Legend like our
arguably the best tennis player ever
certainly the best on Earth right now
Novak Djokovic he is unvaxxed he was
unable to play in a couple major tennis
tournaments over the past couple years
his argument was hey I'm young and
healthy tennis it's just one guy and
another guy on the other side and a one
ball we're not breathing all over each
other I'm taking care of myself I get
plenty of Sun I eat right I'm like the
peak of physical health like why should
I take this vax they are still not
letting him in the United States right
now think about how freaking insane that
is I guess it shouldn't be thought of as
freaking insane considering only two
days ago the harpies at the view let
their own audience take their masks off
I mean for me it's just like hard to
believe that people still live in that
reality but okay so that's happening
right now no uh Novak Djokovic cannot
get in the United States so uh Governor
DeSantis over here in the Free State of
Florida he's trying to come up with a
creative way to make it happen
which I think as you guys know you know
number one tennis player uh one of the
best ever he is being discriminated
against because he didn't take the mnra
kova jab and he never wanted to do it
from the beginning and you know what
there are people in Florida who never
wanted to do it and we fought for your
right to make that choice without losing
your job or having this stuff
and so
not only has he not wanted to take it we
now have the data to show these booster
shots aren't preventing you from getting
infected people get infected anyways and
so you know it's like okay now you have
this this this Rule and we're one of the
only countries in the world that has
this rule that you have to show shot
records to come in as a foreign visitor
on an airplane Djokovic has already had
covid you know there's something called
natural immunity which the CDC didn't
want to recognize but we all know is a
fact of life and so he poses zero risk
to the United States zero risk to the
State of Florida and zero risk to Miami
so he should be allowed to compete now I
would run a I would run a boat from the
Bahamas here for him I would do that a
hundred percent
but
we are going to have to smuggle in
tennis players on boats from the Bahamas
that's where we're at in this clown car
of endless stupidity but really guys
joking aside the federal government
still does not want unvaccinated people
in this country think how absolutely
insane that is and then put that in
contrast to the beginnings of covid when
we knew it was coming from Wuhan right
whether you thought it was coming from
the lab or from the wet Market or
whatever and Trump said hey we're going
to close the doors to China and everyone
called him racist right now when covet
is basically over we know that vaccines
don't work natural immunity does all of
the stuff we've you know all of the same
people have moved past it and we are
still trying to keep this guy out of the
United States do you think it has
anything to do with covet anymore or
could it have something to do with
control what what do you really think
and if you think it's a joke if you
think it's completely made up that we're
not allowing Djokovic in uh well here's
cringe Jean-Pierre Governor Ron DeSantis
has now called on President Biden to
allow the tennis player Novak Djokovic
to compete in the Miami open despite him
being unvaccinated for coven 19. uh do
you guys have a response to that so on a
question of regarding the vaccination
requirement I refer you to the CDC
they're the ones who uh who deal with
that it's still in place and we expect
everyone to abide by our country's rule
whether as a participant or a spectator
and uh as for what goes on specifically
with the BNP uh open those are those are
questions for them it is a private
entity and so we will let them speak to
that but again this is something that
the CDC uh speaks to
you know the CDC does not rule over you
do you guys know that you know these
people are always concerned about an
Insurrection they care so much about our
institutions and the Constitution and
the government and all of that stuff the
CDC the Center for Disease Control uh is
just a government institution right it
is not an institution that governs you
right we have to abide by the Bill of
Rights and the laws of the federal
government and the the state governments
um but I really don't even know what to
say about these people anymore because
this has nothing to do with the truth so
on one hand they lie about absolutely
everything and then they tell you that
they're the truth tellers it's so
absolutely extraordinary so the question
really is I suppose this is the question
of the day over here at the Reuben
report who is actually trying to fool
you right now do you think I have sat
here for the last 40 minutes and tried
to fool you of anything right like
here's some information I'm being quite
upfront uh well first off I'm also not a
journalist I am some guy trying to
translate some of the insanity I hand it
to you and then you have a brain and
then you can think about it right and
maybe you'll come to a different
conclusion that I have but removing me
from the equation who is lying to you
right now and who's who's let's put it
this way who's trying to get you more to
a narrative and who's trying to get you
more to the truth would you say would
you say it's Tucker or the machine I
want to go back and we're just going to
play 10 seconds of it of the first clip
that we started with today and I really
want you to think about this for just a
second here's Colbert
thanks in large parts to the former
president there's a whole industry of
people who make a good living trying to
make you think you're insane
okay so there's a whole bunch of people
trying to make you feel insane that's
what Colbert is telling you now let's
flash back to this clip of Colbert with
fauci on the street going after
anti-vaxxers and promoting the vax and
you tell me who who's been trying to
make you feel insane take a look are you
worried at all about the new booster no
no no are you are you worried you're not
worried that the the 5G chip that it
puts in you is going to interfere with
the 3G chip from the last one Bill Gates
and I decided we're going to take the
chips out now we're not going to oh
really now I know you want to convince
people to go get this shot right right
that's it's a it's a cool thing to do
right okay what could be more compelling
than getting the shot
with a pair of sexy kitten ears on
all right there you go hello good
afternoon I was wondering whether I
could set my friend up here with uh
covet booster shot absolutely have a
seat great thank you just need to ask
you a few questions sure have you ever
had a coveted vaccination before yes I
have okay and did you have any untoward
reactions to that vaccination and have
you been infected before I have how long
ago was that a little bit over three
months around three months everything
checks out let's get you back all right
let's do it are you nervous to give
Anthony fauci a shot I've done this
plenty of times but it's Anthony bouchy
very nervous that's like pulling a drink
for Jack Daniels are you are you nervous
to give this man a shot he's actually
only the third most famous person I've
vaccinated who's the most famous person
you've vaccinated take a deep breath in
for me who is the most famous person
that's it there's the moment there you
go okay
I can't tell you yes you can
head to vaccines.gov to find booster
shots near you Dr Anthony fauci
everybody so you tell me guys after
watching that now knowing that the
vaccines don't work the boosters don't
work do you know how many people I know
and I'm sure you know too that are so
freaking thrilled that they never
succumbed to the pressure right like I
never succumb to the pressure David
never succumbed to the pressure we got
pretty damn close and we were under all
sorts of pressures like everybody else
family friends blah blah blah and I the
more they push the less I wanted to do
it and I am freaking thrilled and I know
that the three people I'm sitting in
this room with are thrilled that they
didn't do it either I know so many
people
who got a shot got a follow-up got a
booster who are are now looking into all
the ways that you can detox your body
they're concerned as I've told you guys
many times I have a friend who's in his
early 20s who's having heart issues for
the first time I have another friend
who's having a double vision that she
never had before this she's having some
like this stuff is real
so who is lying to you who is
gaslighting you is it Tucker or Carlson
on what he's doing on January 6 or is it
Stephen Colbert and Anthony fauci who
were lying about everything also uh at
the beginning of that where he says to
to fauci you're not worried about the
booster and found no he's not really
you're not still if we could ask you
that question now are you still not
worried about and then they make these
silly jokes about 5G and Bill Gates it's
like every time someone has an inkling
of Truth they want to step on it and
quash it and it's just absolutely insane
and then that he dare says that getting
the vaccine is the cool thing to do but
if you don't think that Stephen Colbert
has debased himself embarrassed himself
like I hope it's worth the cash man you
got a lot of money I get it you got a
lot of money money's good people like
having stuff it's cool you have
absolutely debased yourself but if you
don't think that what we just showed you
is debasing enough to you remember this
one how about watch this one and tell me
who's a propagandist and a liar error
after you see that I mean this one is
just this should go down and they should
study this on other planets
foreign
[Music]
clown and that's all that he is no
offense Bozo there are some respectable
clowns out there
but you have a millionaire clown doing
the dirty work for the NIH doing the
dirty work for pharmaceutical companies
dancing around like a buffoon telling
you to inject something in your body and
then telling you that the people who are
a bit skeptical of it whether it's
Tucker Carlson whether it's me whether
it's you we're the bad guys we're the
Bad Guys what do we do about all this
guys how do we tie a show like this
together so that you you feel good
because this is a lot of nonsense right
like it's a lot of nonsense and it's not
it's not it doesn't feel good to have to
deal with this nonsense but there are
ways to feel good and there are uh well
there are plenty of ways to feel good uh
whatever your choice might be be it the
tequila or the weed or sitting quietly
in nature whatever whatever you like but
there are people out there who are
breaking through the thing right and
that's what's happening also and that's
also why they want to censor everybody
and everything else one of the main guys
right now who is breaking through the
thing and we've seen it we've seen it
right when Russ when uh let's say Joe
Rogan at first was really breaking
through the machine and then the machine
started calling him racist and you see
these little blips of people getting
through I think the main guy getting
through right now is Russell Brand as I
said I have some political disagreements
with Russell Brand we discussed a few of
them yesterday and we'll put the video
up uh next week but he is a good decent
man and he's trying to bring something
true to the people
he's trying to do something true for
himself first I think and then translate
that across to other people uh here he
is is just a little bit him on Rogan a
couple days ago talking about God and
belief and how that is a key piece of
how you can cope with the world
especially a world that is filled with
just so much unrelenting BS Russell
Brand has been an actor a comedian a
podcast host for decades all of a sudden
he's one of the most forceful voices for
the truth in the English-speaking world
is also a deeply interesting person with
a lot of insights about God amazingly
Russell Brand we sat down with him for a
long conversation a brand new episode
Tucker Carlson today here's a small part
of it
[Music]
as much as I might enjoy the feeling of
privilege and luxury and I'm certainly
making no claims to be an aesthetic I
remember what reality is I remember that
my Wellness is contingent upon spiritual
connection upon certain values and
principles and they I am sorry to admit
involves sacrifice and self-scrutiny
about my own conduct and behavior which
is often will often fall short and I'm
working on improving myself I continue
to work on improving myself so when I
sort of hear morality sort of as bombast
or when I hear rhetoric divorce from
compassion it makes me feel uneasy so
I've been blessed with a very practical
spirituality like many desperate people
I need spirituality I need God or I
cannot COPE in this world I need to
believe in the best in people I need to
believe that there are new alliances
possible new ways of us communicating
because I see atrophying and corrupt
systems delivering get more misery to
people and I think it's increasingly
necessary that we find new ways of
framing the conversation and looking
into our hearts when we're speaking
all right so that was obviously Russell
talking to Tucker I think I said he was
talking to to Joe there uh but he did
have an excellent interview with Joe
last week which was on my mind that's
why I said it but uh the point there is
there are some people who were trying to
do something honest I think he's on that
list I think there are way more people
than we think like they're not all
public people right like private people
that are trying to find something that
is true uh to incorporate a a decent
honest life in a way that is cogent in a
time of complete utter chaos you know
it's interesting that he said the thing
about God that you know in essence he
needs God it reminds me of a line I
can't believe I'm going to quote this
guy but I had John Kasich on John Kasich
was a former uh governor of Ohio he ran
for president against Trump you know
first time around and uh we had him at
the house and I was interviewing him and
we talked a bit about spirituality which
was not my intention when I sat down
with him and he said something that I
thought was really interesting it's a
line that I've used a couple times he
said you know a lot of people could do
it without God I'm not one of those
people and that's kind of what Russell
Brand just said right there
so that to end all of this whether you
believe in God or something don't just
believe in the government
and don't just believe the machine if
the machine wants you to believe
anything it can make you believe
anything and that is why so many people
have gone crazy over the last couple
years so find the people that are doing
something to find that that true north
that star that truth something or other
and I think that is how we will get out
of this that's a bit of what I discussed
with Russell and again that'll be up
next week we got a post game show for
you in just moments for subscribers at
reubenreport.locals.com and by the way
Russell announced yesterday that he is
releasing his new stand-up special in a
couple weeks exclusively on locals I
mean really for me like think how cool
that is like I had this little idea a
couple years ago of creating this tech
company really just so that I could fund
this show that was it we weren't going
to spin it off into anything else it was
like how do we build a subscription
model so I can keep doing what I want
and build my company and that sort of
thing and then we
obviously decided to you know become the
startup and raise the funds and
everything else and then now with
everything going on with Rumble and with
Russell breaking through and that the
guys releasing his stand-up show on on
the platform that I was you know just
had this dream of creating like it's
really freaking cool and it just shows
you if you try guys something good might
happen uh the special is called
brandemic and it's going to be out on
March 13th that's just in a couple days
uh part two of my interview with Carol
Markowitz and Bethany Mandel both great
actual journalists who are also Mama
bears who were sick of their kids
getting abused by the system they have a
new book out uh we did that live in
Miami last week that's up right now full
things on locals we leave you with Joe
Biden and we'll get to comments
questions Corrections and whatever else
you got for me on locals in just a sec
all right see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]